The People's Almanac came out in the mid 1970s-- it's hard to imagine a more eccentric bestseller. Over 1,400 pages long, it read like an encyclopedia written by an excited and precocious 15-year-old who loved all the obscure details of all the knowledge in all the world.
《人民年鉴》出版于20世纪70年代中期——很难想象还有比这更古怪的畅销书了。它厚达1400多页，读起来就像一本百科全书，由一个兴奋且早熟的15岁少年编写，他热爱世界上所有知识中那些晦涩的细节。
There are sections on the greatest man-made disasters ever, and also on the greatest prizefighters, a guide to buried treasure in the United States, biographies of famous and infamous scientists, a history of advertising going back to ancient Greece, and also a chapter about a minister who took over a newspaper for a week in the year 1900 and made all editorial decisions-- what was on the front page, what they covered, based on what he believed Jesus would have done, if Jesus had gone into the newspaper game. And at the end of the book was an address and a note from the authors asking for suggestions for future editions, and asking readers to tell them what parts of the book they liked and disliked.
书中既有关于史上最严重的人造灾难的章节，也有关于最伟大拳击手的介绍；有美国埋藏宝藏的指南、著名和臭名昭著科学家的传记、追溯到古希腊的广告史，还有一章讲述了一位牧师在1900年接管报社一周的故事，他基于自己认为耶稣如果进入报业会怎么做——比如头版放什么、报道什么——来做出所有的编辑决策。书的结尾是作者的地址和一封给读者的信，请求他们为未来版本提供建议，并询问他们喜欢和不喜欢书中的哪些部分。
So we eventually received thousands of letters, each of which I read.
最终我们收到了成千上万封信，每一封我都读了。
David Wallechinsky was one of the authors of The People's Almanac.
大卫·瓦莱钦斯基（David Wallechinsky）是《人民年鉴》的作者之一。
And because of that, I was able to determine that the most popular chapter in The People's Almanac was lists.
正因如此，我得以确定《人民年鉴》中最受欢迎的章节是“列表”。
Lists! Of all the knowledge in the world, people most loved 25 pages, out of the 1,400-page book, that had some lists. Some of those lists were boring stuff, like the world's 15 biggest cities and 10 tallest buildings and 10 longest rivers. But there were weirder lists-- 20 historical figures who were born as illegitimate children, 15 people who had an absurd number of spouses.
列表！在世界上所有的知识中，人们最喜欢这本1400页书中的25页列表内容。其中一些列表比较乏味，比如世界15大城市、10座最高建筑和10条最长河流。但也有更古怪的列表——20位私生子出身的历史人物，15位拥有荒谬配偶数量的人。
And this one that was maybe a little more edgy in 1975 when this was published-- 20 celebrities who've been psychoanalyzed. From the letters they got, Wallechinsky says that they learned that one list that readers really loved was--
还有这个在1975年出版时可能稍微有些前卫的列表——20位接受过精神分析的名人。瓦莱钦斯基说，从他们收到的信件中得知，读者最喜欢的一个列表是——
Famous people who never existed, but live today, like Sherlock Holmes, Superman, Wonder Woman, Scrooge McDuck.
从未存在但如今依然活跃的名人，比如夏洛克·福尔摩斯、超人、神奇女侠、史高治·麦克达克。
Scrooge McDuck, not technically a person, but you get the idea.
史高治·麦克达克，严格来说不是一个人，但你明白我的意思。
And the most popular list was "Nine Breeds of Dog that Bite the Most." So based on that, we decided to do the first Book of Lists.
而最受欢迎的列表是“最常咬人的九种狗”。基于此，我们决定制作第一本《列表之书》。
The first Book of Lists was an even bigger, even more ridiculously huge bestseller, a pop culture phenomenon. It sold over three million copies, had four sequels, a short-lived TV spin off, and a board game. I was a teenager in the 1970s. I had no interest in this kind of thing whatsoever, but I remember it being one of those ubiquitous books that you could not help but know about.
第一本《列表之书》成了一本规模更大、更荒谬的超级畅销书，一种流行文化现象。它卖出了超过三百万册，出了四本续集，还有一个短命的电视衍生节目和一款桌面游戏。我在70年代是个十几岁的孩子。我对这种东西毫无兴趣，但我记得它是一本那种随处可见、让你不得不了解的书。
And looking back on it now, reading The Book of Lists today, I think they accidentally figured out how to give the pleasure of scrolling the internet way before the internet existed. Basically, it was a way to leaf through impossibly random stuff until something catchy grabbed your eye.
现在回过头来看，今天读《列表之书》，我认为他们无意中在互联网出现之前很久，就摸索出了如何提供那种浏览互联网的乐趣。基本上，这是一种翻阅极其随机内容的方式，直到有什么吸引眼球的东西抓住你的注意力。
We had different kinds of lists. And people were responding to all of them. We had the celebrity lists, where we would ask Ronald Reagan, what are the events in history you wish you could have witnessed? Then there were the straight lists that were statistical-- what were the worst airlines in the world based on deaths per miles flown? And then my favorite kind were what we call the annotated lists, where you'd actually have to do some research and then put a paragraph describing the entry.
我们有各种各样的列表。人们对所有这些都有回应。我们有名人列表，我们会问罗纳德·里根，你希望亲眼见证历史上的哪些事件？然后是统计类的直白列表——基于每飞行英里死亡人数计算的世界最差航空公司是哪些？而我最喜欢的是我们称之为“注释列表”的那种，你需要进行一些研究，然后写一段文字来描述这个条目。
The most popular list they ever did was like that. And before I tell you what this list was, I want you to please listen for a second to some of the lists that it had to beat out to be the most popular list.
他们做过的最受欢迎的列表就是那样的。在告诉你这个列表是什么之前，我想请你先听听它必须击败哪些列表才能成为最受欢迎的。
OK, here we go. [CLEARS THROAT] 15 famous events that happened in the bathtub. 16 names of things that you never knew had names. 18 famous brains and what they weighed. 14 men who became units of measurement and the units named after them. Benjamin Franklin's 8 reasons to marry an older woman. A lot of competition there. So what was in that most popular list?
好的，我们开始。[清嗓子] 15件发生在浴缸里的著名事件。16种你从未知道有名字的事物的名称。18个著名大脑及其重量。14个变成了计量单位的男人，以及以他们命名的单位。本杰明·富兰克林的8条娶年长女性的理由。竞争非常激烈。那么那个最受欢迎的列表里有什么？
Six sexual positions in order of popularity, and then the advantages and disadvantages of each one. Decades later, people still tell me, thank you so much for that list. I learned so much. [LAUGHS]
按受欢迎程度排序的六种性爱姿势，以及每种姿势的优缺点。几十年后，人们仍然告诉我，非常感谢那个列表。我学到了很多。[笑]
And maybe this is obvious on its face, but just lay out why that would be such a big deal in the '70s.
也许这显而易见，但请说明为什么这在70年代会是一件大事。
I think it was a big deal because nobody talked about it. It wasn't in print. And I think a lot of people only thought there was one sexual position.
我认为这是一件大事，因为没人谈论它。它没有被印刷出来。而且我认为很多人只以为只有一种性爱姿势。
No.
不。
Yeah. Oh, yeah. I mean, there were people like that. And a lot of the people who would tell me about how it affected them, they read it at a time when they were teenagers.
是的。噢，是的。我是说，确实有那样的人。很多告诉我它如何影响他们的人，是在青少年时期读到的。
It's interesting, I just opened it up to that page in the book. And these are so basic. It literally is just like, which person is on top--
很有趣，我刚好翻到了书的那一页。这些内容太基础了。字面上真的就像是，哪个人在上面——
Yeah.
是的。
--and whether they're sort of lying, sitting, or standing. And each position gets five sentences maybe-- a sentence of advantage, a sentence of disadvantage. It's very terse. It's two pages total.
——以及他们是躺着、坐着还是站着。每个姿势可能也就五句话——一句优点，一句缺点。非常简洁。总共只有两页。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's not the Kama Sutra.
是的，是的，是的。它不是《爱经》。
David Wallechinsky has thought way more about lists than most of us. And he told me this one story that illustrates how putting something on a list has such power. He said that for most of his adult life, he was kind of obsessed about the terrible things that repressive governments around the world do to their people. And he wanted to write about it for magazines and convince people how important this was. And he really couldn't figure out how to do that compellingly.
大卫·瓦莱钦斯基对列表的思考远超我们大多数人。他告诉我一个故事，展示了将事物列入列表具有怎样的力量。他说，在他成年后的大部分时间里，他一直痴迷于世界各地的压制性政府对人民所做的可怕事情。他想为杂志撰文，并让人相信这有多重要。但他真的想不出如何以令人信服的方式来做。
And so in 2003, I got this idea. I'll do it as a list-- the 10 worst living dictators. And I was obsessive in creating the order of the list of worst dictators. I had criteria, different criteria. And then I gave extra credit for dictators who tortured or murdered their political opponents.
于是，2003年，我有了这个主意。我把它做成一个列表——10位最糟糕的在世独裁者。我在创建最糟糕独裁者列表的顺序时非常痴迷。我有标准，不同的标准。然后我给那些折磨或谋杀政治对手的独裁者加了分。
He published this list, with write-ups on each dictator, in Parade Magazine, which was a big deal at the time. It reached 32 million people.
他将这份列表连同对每位独裁者的描述一起发表在《游行》杂志上，这在当时是一件大事。它覆盖了3200万人。
And it was so popular that we did it annually. And it became a cover story. So millions of people read about this topic they would not otherwise have read about. The list format made accessible to people a subject they didn't know they might be interested in.
它太受欢迎了，以至于我们每年都做。它成了封面故事。所以数百万人阅读了这个他们本不会关注的话题。列表格式让人们能够接触到他们可能不知道自己感兴趣的主题。
It made the subject digestible and human. Here were 10 awful human beings you could have feelings about. That's the power of a list. But of course, most of the lists in our lives are different from this. Most are the lists that we write for ourselves. And it's interesting. People put all kinds of things on those lists.
它让主题变得易于消化且人性化。这里有10个你可以产生情绪的糟糕人类。这就是列表的力量。但当然，我们生活中大多数列表与此不同。大多数是我们为自己写的列表。这很有趣。人们在这些列表上列出了各种各样的事情。
Oh, my god. I feel nervous.
噢，天哪。我感到紧张。
Why do you feel nervous?
你为什么感到紧张？
Because I was just looking through my list, and I just feel like a freak.
因为我刚才翻看了我的列表，我觉得自己像个怪胎。
This is Aviva DeKornfeld, a producer at our show here. And I learned about the very personal and idiosyncratic lists that she keeps in a staff meeting where I talked about Wallechinsky and different kinds of lists. And at that meeting, Aviva started talking about her lists.
这是艾薇娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld），我们节目的制作人。我在一次员工会议上谈到瓦莱钦斯基和各种列表时，了解到了她保留的那些非常私人且独特的列表。在那次会议上，艾薇娃开始谈论她的列表。
And so I was offering this, kind of assuming I would start saying my lists and then everyone else would be like, yeah, yeah, me too. And then they would share their lists, and it would be kind of like this bonding moment.
所以我提出这一点时，默认我会开始说我的列表，然后其他人会说，是的，我也是。然后他们会分享他们的列表，这会是一种情感联结的时刻。
That's what you thought was going to happen?
你以为会发生那种事？
Yeah. And that's not what happened at all. What happened is that I named a couple of my more recent lists. And then everyone started laughing and was like, what the hell? In fact, Laura, our coworker, messaged in the chat, "Aviva's brain," with like seven exclamation points. And it felt a little-- I mean, it was all in good spirits, but it felt a little embarrassing.
是的。但根本没发生那种事。发生的是，我说了几个我最近的列表。然后每个人都开始笑，说，搞什么鬼？事实上，我们的同事劳拉在聊天中发了“艾薇娃的大脑”，后面还带了七个感叹号。这感觉有点——我是说，大家都没有恶意，但这感觉有点尴尬。
Aviva does keep some lists that lots of people keep-- practical stuff like books she wants to read or gift ideas for people she loves. But then on the Notes app of her phone, there's a whole bunch of lists that have no practical purpose at all, but are really just her organizing the stuff that is rattling around in her head.
艾薇娃确实保留了一些许多人都会保留的列表——一些实用的东西，比如她想读的书或送给她所爱之人的礼物创意。但随后在手机的笔记应用里，有一大堆列表根本没有任何实用目的，而纯粹是她在整理脑子里乱转的东西。
So a list that is just organizing my brain is-- let me look-- things that are off-brand for me, or common things I've never done, or times strangers have involved me in their business for unclear reasons, like on the street or on the subway. That happens to me all the time.
所以一个只是整理我大脑的列表是——让我看看——不符合我风格的事情，或者是常见的但我从未做过的事情，或者是陌生人因为不明原因把我卷入他们事务的时刻，比如在街上或地铁上。这种事总是发生在我身上。
OK, so then let's dive into those lists. Things that are off-brand for me--
好的，那我们就深入探讨一下那些列表。不符合我风格的事情——
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
--read me that list.
——读给我听听。
OK. I'm bad at jumping. I'm inconsistent with my birth control.
好的。我不擅长跳跃。我对避孕药的使用很不规律。
You mean you're not taking your pill every day that you should?
你是说你没有按时每天吃药吗？
No.
不是。
Why is that off-brand?
那为什么这不符合你的风格？
Because I'm organized. The other thing that's embarrassing about reading these lists is that they're so private. But whatever, I don't care. I can't rollerblade. I hate PETA, even though I was vegan for a year and vegetarian for a bunch of years. I just really don't like them.
因为我很有条理。读这些列表令人尴尬的另一件事是它们太私密了。但无所谓，我不在乎。我不会玩轮滑。我讨厌善待动物组织（PETA），尽管我做过一年的纯素食者和几年的素食者。我只是真的很不喜欢他们。
I don't love bowling. That's a new addition. The last one I really don't want to share, but will. But it probably shouldn't be on the radio because it makes me seem really psychotic, which is that I've never kissed anyone famous. And I just assumed I would have by now.
我不喜欢打保龄球。这是一个新的增加项。最后一条我真的不想分享，但还是会说。但这可能不应该在广播里说，因为它让我看起来真的很精神病，那就是我从未吻过任何名人。我一直以为我到现在应该吻过了。
Because you're how old?
因为你多大？
30.
30岁。
And so you've kissed a bunch of people.
你吻过很多人吗？
Yeah, a ton. And the most famous person I've ever kissed is the captain of the Belgian field hockey team, which is not famous.
是的，一大堆。我吻过的最著名的人是比利时曲棍球队的队长，那根本算不上名人。
No, that is not famous.
不，那不算名人。
No. Yeah, his name was Jay.
不。是的，他叫杰伊。
This list, or the list "Common things I've never done"-- which, by the way, only has two items on it, karaoke and going to Costco-- or the list, "Where I feel the emotions that I feel on my body," or the list, "Times people have referred to me as neurodivergent, even though I don't think I am"-- all these lists are different ways that Aviva is naming parts of herself for herself.
这个列表，或者“我从未做过的常见事情”这个列表——顺便说一下，上面只有两项，卡拉OK和去Costco——或者“我在身体哪里感受到我所感受到的情绪”列表，或者“人们称我为神经多样性患者的时刻，尽管我认为我不是”列表——所有这些列表都是艾薇娃为自己命名她自身不同部分的方式。
Yeah. Yeah, I'm just trying to make sense of who I am and what is going on in my brain.
是的。是的，我只是试图弄清楚我是谁，我的大脑里在发生什么。
In list form.
以列表的形式。
Yeah, because it's so organized and clear and clean. And the business of making sense of yourself I've found to be extremely messy.
是的，因为它如此有条理、清晰且整洁。而我发现搞清楚自己是谁这件事是非常混乱的。
With that in mind, Aviva still keeps old defunct lists because they're like a record of who she was-- lists from when she was a teenager, like "Harmless things my dad hates," or "Things I should have known," or her very first list, "Scenes from my grandmother's nursing home"-- made on weekly visits when she was 14, trying to make sense of that world.
考虑到这一点，艾薇娃仍然保留着旧的、作废的列表，因为它们就像她过去经历的记录——她青少年时期的列表，比如“我爸讨厌的无害事情”或“我本该知道的事情”，或者她第一个列表，“我祖母疗养院的场景”——这是她14岁时每周探望时做的，试图理解那个世界。
Normally, she doesn't show these lists to anybody. She'd just notice something about herself, and then she'll notice a second example of the same thing, and she starts to collect them so she can stare at the list, try to understand it.
通常，她不会给任何人看这些列表。她只是会注意到关于自己的一些事情，然后她会注意到同一事情的第二个例子，她就开始收集它们，这样她就可以盯着这个列表，试着去理解它。
And the fact that it's collected on a list, what feeling does that give you, once it's on the list?
列表收集起来后，一旦出现在列表上，它给了你什么感觉？
Oh, my god, it's like relief. It's so nice. Because it's just bouncing around in my brain. And so once it's on a list, I don't feel like I have to remember it.
噢，天哪，这简直是一种解脱。太棒了。因为它只是在我脑子里蹦来蹦去。一旦它出现在列表上，我就觉得我不需要记住它了。
But it isn't just you don't have to think about it. It's like you don't have to worry about it. Before you put it on the list, it seems like there's a kind of fretting of like, what does this mean about me that this is a thing? And then once you put it on the list, you're like, I know what it means. It means it's on this list.
但不仅仅是你不需要去想它。这就像你不需要去担心它一样。在你把它放在列表上之前，似乎有一种焦躁，比如，这件事意味着什么？一旦你把它放在列表上，你就会想，我知道它意味着什么。这意味着它在这个列表上。
Yeah, totally. That's true. I exist, and this is a thing about me.
是的，完全正确。这是真的。我存在，而这是关于我的一件事。
Today, on our program, lists, and how they tame the chaos of the world. I have to say, I feel very aware in putting together everything that I have said to you so far today. The way I did it is the way I write every radio story I've ever done since, I don't know, forever.
今天，在我们的节目中，讨论列表，以及它们如何驯服世界的混乱。我必须说，我在整理今天对你所说的一切时感到非常清醒。我的方式就是我编写每一个广播故事的方式，从我不知道什么时候开始就一直是这样。
The first thing I do is I make a list of all the possible quotes that I might use. So in this case, it was three single-spaced typed pages of quotes from Aviva and from David Wallechinsky, with asterisks by the quotes I like the most. And then what I do is I stare at the list until it just pops out for me. This quote should come first, and this one second, and this one should end the thing. I have no idea how to write any radio story without a list to take control of all the confusion and all the possible choices that I could make and make it make sense.
我做的第一件事是列出所有我可能要用的引语。所以在这个案例中，这是三页单倍行距的打印纸，上面全是来自艾薇娃和大卫·瓦莱钦斯基的引语，我喜欢的引语旁边会有星号。然后我要做的就是盯着列表，直到它对我跳出来。这段话应该先出现，这段话第二，这段话应该结束整件事。我不知道如何在没有列表来控制所有混乱和所有可能做出的选择的情况下，编写任何广播故事。
So today, lists, how they run the world and everything in it. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And hold on, I have a list right here. Number 1, stay with us. Number 2, stay with us. Number 3, stay with us.
所以今天，列表，它们如何掌控世界及其中的一切。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。等等，我这里有个列表。第一，留下来。第二，留下来。第三，留下来。
It's This American Life, Act 1, "List for Life." So let's start our show today with a list designed as a kind of magical tool for living your life and maximizing your potential and being your very best self. Or anyway, that's what this list was supposed to do. The story comes to us from John Fecile.
这是《美国生活》，第一幕，“生活列表”。所以今天让我们从一个旨在作为一种生活魔法工具的列表开始，它能最大化你的潜力，成为最好的自己。或者说，这个列表本该如此。这个故事由约翰·费西尔（John Fecile）带来。
You ready to talk about the list?
你准备好谈谈这个列表了吗？
Sure.
当然。
You want to see it? It's right-- this is it right here.
你想看看它吗？就在这儿——这就是它。
What do you want to ask me about it?
你想问我关于它什么？
I'm on a Zoom call with my brother Pat, talking about a list that was written by our other brother, Mike. And I want to ask him what he thinks I should do with it. It's one of the last pieces of Mike's writing that we have.
我正和我的兄弟帕特通过Zoom通话，谈论我们另一个兄弟麦克写的一份列表。我想问他觉得我该拿它怎么办。这是我们拥有的麦克最后的遗作之一。
What do you think should be done with this list?
你觉得应该拿这个列表怎么办？
I don't care.
我不在乎。
If you burned it, I wouldn't feel sad. I wouldn't be angry. I'd say, why'd you burn it without me?
如果你把它烧了，我不会感到难过。我不会生气。我会说，你为什么不叫我一起烧？
My brother Mike died in 2015. That's almost 10 years ago now. Jeez. And trigger warning and all that, he died because of a suicidal act. It's unclear why he did what he did. There were stories his roommates told about paranoia, hallucinations, Mike becoming obsessed with aliens.
我兄弟麦克于2015年去世了。那已经是快10年前的事了。天哪。还有那些预警之类的话，他是因为自杀行为去世的。他不明白自己为什么那么做。他室友讲过关于妄想、幻觉的故事，说麦克开始沉迷于外星人。
It was all so sudden and shocking that my family and I started grasping around for anything, trying to make it all make sense, which brings me to the list. Mike wrote the list the summer he was about to be a sophomore in high school-- 16 principles to live his life by, titled, "Goals for Success," double underlined on a rectangular piece of poster board.
这一切太突然、太令人震惊了，以至于我和家人开始抓取任何东西，试图让这一切变得合理，这就带到了这个列表。麦克在他高一升二的那个暑假写下了这份列表——16条他要遵循的生活原则，标题为“成功目标”，在一块长方形海报板上双下划线标出。
They were corny bro-isms, if I'm being honest. "Make a commitment. Be unselfish. Create unity. Come together as never before." As you can see, Mike was a real overachiever, Type A type. "Improve every day as a player, person, and student. Be tough. Be self-disciplined-- do it right, don't accept less."
老实说，它们都是些老套的兄弟主义。“做出承诺。无私奉献。创造团结。以前所未有的方式聚在一起。”如你所见，麦克是个不折不扣的奋斗者，A型人格。“每天作为球员、个人和学生都在进步。坚强。自律——做正确的事，不要接受更差的。”
He was captain of the high school football team, straight-A student. "Give great effort. Be enthusiastic. Eliminate mistakes. Don't beat yourself." He hung the list on his closet door, facing his bed, so that when he woke up in the morning, the first thing he saw was-- "Expect to win. Be consistent. Develop leadership. Be responsible."
他是高中橄榄球队的队长，全优学生。“付出巨大的努力。充满热情。消除错误。不要自暴自弃。”他把列表挂在衣柜门上，正对着他的床，这样当他早上醒来时，他看到的第一件事就是——“期待胜利。保持一致。发展领导力。承担责任。”
I first noticed the list when I went into Mike's bedroom to steal a pair of his boxers. I was always forgetting to do my laundry. Mike always did his. And my feelings about the list were immediately complicated. I felt like it was somehow judging me. I was the oldest of my siblings. But to me, Mike always felt older.
我第一次注意到这份列表，是我进麦克的卧室偷他的一条平角裤时。我总是忘记洗衣服。麦克总是自己洗。我对这个列表的感受立刻变得复杂。我觉得它似乎在评判我。我是兄弟姐妹中最大的。但对我来说，麦克总觉得更成熟。
He was Mr. Rotary Club, Mr. Scheduled Out His Daily Routine. I was Mr. Been Arrested Twice, Mr. Smoking Weed out of an Aluminum Can and Probably Doing Irreparable Damage to my Lungs in the Woods. And Mike knew he was better than me. He even wrote a poem in English class about how disappointed he was in me. I'm not kidding. It was titled "Second Chances."
他是扶轮社先生，是制定每日行程先生。我是被逮捕过两次先生，是用铝罐抽大麻可能正在对肺部造成不可逆损害先生。麦克知道他比我好。他甚至在英语课上写了一首诗，关于他对我有多失望。我没开玩笑。标题叫“第二次机会”。
Back then, I resented the list. I probably made fun of him about it because that was the nature of our relationship, even though we were close. But after he died, I actually saw these principles as something I should live up to. Because at that point, I was spiraling. Mike was 24 when he died. I was 26. I couldn't get myself together-- drinking, depression, a simmering, futile anger at the universe.
当时，我讨厌这份列表。我可能因为这个取笑过他，因为这就是我们关系的样子，尽管我们很亲密。但在他去世后，我实际上把这些原则看作是我应该活出的样子。因为那时，我正处于螺旋式下降中。麦克去世时24岁。我26岁。我无法振作起来——酗酒、抑郁、对宇宙怀有一种闷烧的、徒劳的愤怒。
The original had been framed. And I asked my parents if I could have it, and hung it up in my apartment by the front door. I thought maybe its commandments might rub off on me. And there it stayed for a bit. I'd glance at it every once in a while and feel again like I was falling short.
原件被装裱了起来。我问父母我能不能留着它，然后把它挂在我公寓的前门旁。我想也许它的戒律能熏陶我。它在那儿挂了一阵子。我会偶尔瞥它一眼，然后再次感到自己做得不够好。
So after a couple of years, I took it down. I shoved it in the back of my closet. It just bothered me, the toxic positivity, therapist-waiting-room-posterness of it all. But I also couldn't bear to get rid of it, which is why I called up Pat to finally figure out what to do with it.
所以几年后，我把它取了下来。我把它塞进了衣柜后面。它只是困扰着我，那种有毒的积极性，那种治疗师候诊室的海报感。但我也舍不得扔掉它，这就是我打电话给帕特去最终决定该怎么办的原因。
If anything, I would think the list would be cursed. So you can keep it if it makes you feel better. I don't want anything to do with the list.
如果要说的话，我会觉得这份列表是被诅咒的。所以如果你觉得留着它让你感觉好点，你就留着吧。我不想和它有任何关系。
Pat was the closest person to Mike in the world. He's two years younger than Mike, who was a year and a half younger than me. Pat and I can't even agree on the most basic things about the list.
帕特是麦克在世界上最亲近的人。他比麦克小两岁，麦克比我小一岁半。帕特甚至不能和我对这个列表最基本的事情达成一致。
And he had neat handwriting. That was one thing that struck me, looking at the list, is how neat his handwriting is.
他字迹工整。这是我看着列表时印象深刻的一点，他的字迹多么工整。
It doesn't look neat, not to me.
它看起来不工整，对我来说不是。
Yeah way!
明明就是！
Are those straight lines? Are we looking at the same photo?
那是直线吗？我们在看同一张照片吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
No, that's not neat.
不，那不工整。
That's neat.
那很工整。
Look at the K. He doesn't even dot the i's.
看那个K。他甚至没点i的圆点。
But he's consistently not dotting his i's. That says something.
但他一直都不点i的圆点。这说明了什么。
That he never learned how to write the letter i?
说明他从未学会如何写字母i？
Pat saw something in the list that I also felt, but I couldn't necessarily name.
帕特在列表中看到了我也感受到的东西，但我无法准确说出名字。
What role do you think the list played in his death?
你觉得这份列表在他的死亡中扮演了什么角色？
The list didn't play a role, but it's a reflection of his psychology, which played every role in his death and shows you the type of responsibility he felt. It shows you the type of pressure he put on himself. There's nothing about self-care in it. And there's nothing about being true to yourself either. It shows you a lot of what was going on with him and this mindset that he got trapped in and that made him very sick.
列表没起作用，但它是他心理的反映，这在他的死亡中起了全部作用，并向你展示了他感受到的责任感类型。它展示了他施加给自己的压力类型。里面没有任何关于自我关怀的内容。也没有任何关于忠于自我的内容。它向你展示了他身上发生的很多事情，以及他陷入的那种让他病得很重的心态。
When Mike was a sophomore at Penn State, he started experiencing delusions and he was barely sleeping. But if he felt like he was struggling, he didn't tell anyone. He kept going to class. His roommates noticed. And they were talking about how to get him help. And I think, this is just my opinion, a guess, that Mike didn't want to be found out.
麦克在宾夕法尼亚州立大学读大二时，开始出现妄想，几乎无法入睡。但如果他觉得自己在挣扎，他不会告诉任何人。他继续上课。他的室友注意到了。他们正在讨论如何给他提供帮助。而我认为，这只是我的观点，猜测而已，麦克不想被发现。
In the past, I've connected the list to Mike's mindset, as in, he was not somebody who's going to be vulnerable if he was suffering.
过去，我把列表和麦克的心态联系在一起，意思是，他不是那种在遭受痛苦时会表现出脆弱的人。
No, he was not.
不，他不是。
Are there any bullet points that stand out to you in particular?
有什么特别突出的条目吗？
There's a bunch. "Eliminate mistakes," that's one of the ones that's just so stupid. Eliminate mistakes? What do you mean?
有很多。 “消除错误”，这是其中太蠢的例子之一。消除错误？你什么意思？
You can't.
你做不到。
How?
怎么做？
That's why they're mistakes.
那就是它们是错误的原因。
Yeah. "Create unity. Come together as never before." I mean, he's not just trying to get people to come together, "as never before."
是的。“创造团结。以前所未有的方式聚在一起。” 我是说，他不只是试图让人们聚在一起，“以前所未有的方式”。
[LAUGHS] I like that one. That reminds me of, he was a good unifier. He had friends across all the arbitrary social cliques.
[笑] 我喜欢那一条。这让我想起他是个很好的团结者。他在所有随意的社交圈子里都有朋友。
After he passed, did you think about the list at all?
在他去世后，你有没有想过这个列表？
I didn't give it a lot of thought until I went to the football banquet and heard Mr. Ricci speak. And then I got pretty angry. And then I was pretty annoyed at the list.
我没怎么想它，直到我去参加橄榄球宴会，听了里奇教练的演讲。然后我很生气。然后我很讨厌这个列表。
One of the captains of our 2008 team and a 2009 Garnet Valley graduate, Mike Fecile, embodied the qualities of the coachable player.
我们2008年队的队长之一，2009年Garnet Valley的毕业生，麦克·费西尔，体现了可教球员的素质。
That's Mike's high school football coach, in case you can't just tell from his voice, renaming an award after my brother at a banquet in 2016.
那是麦克的高中橄榄球教练，如果你听不出他的声音的话，他在2016年的宴会上以我兄弟的名字重新命名了一个奖项。
Mike created and shared a list of goals for success, 16 standards that he vowed to uphold and to use as a compass to guide his path. They were, "Make a commitment. Be unselfish."
麦克创建并分享了一份成功目标列表，16个他发誓要坚持并作为导航指南的准则。它们是，“做出承诺。无私奉献。”
This is really the moment the list passed into lore, when it became the way my brother was remembered. The coach paid to have Goals for Success professionally matted and framed. That's the copy that I have.
这确实是列表成为传奇的时刻，当它成为纪念我兄弟的方式时。教练花钱将“成功目标”专业地装裱了起来。那就是我拥有的那份拷贝。
He also hung a replica of the list in our high school's weight room, next to a photo of Mike in football gear, with his tough game face on to inspire future generations, which I appreciated. He was putting so much into memorializing Mike. But later, I started worrying about the kids who saw it and whether they might judge themselves by it the same way that I had.
他还把这份列表的复制品挂在我们高中的举重室里，旁边是麦克穿着橄榄球装备、一脸坚毅比赛表情的照片，以激励后代，对此我很感激。他投入了这么多来纪念麦克。但后来，我开始担心那些看到它的孩子们，以及他们是否会像我一样用它来评判自己。
We want our players to do what you're supposed to do and believe if it is to be, it's up to me. We want them to be model citizens, model athletes, and model sons. In essence, we want them to be like Mike Fecile.
我们希望我们的球员做你应该做的事，相信如果事情要发生，那得靠我。我们希望他们成为模范公民、模范运动员和模范儿子。本质上，我们希望他们像麦克·费西尔一样。
The coach goes on to describe what happened to Mike. He says that he fell from the fourth floor balcony of his dorm and that it was an accident, which he got from my parents. That was how they framed it. But Mike didn't fall. He jumped.
教练继续描述麦克发生了什么。他说他从宿舍四楼的阳台上掉了下来，那是一场意外，这是他从我父母那里得知的。他们就是这样表述的。但麦克没有掉下去。他跳了下去。
The list still makes me feel sad. But that was when the list started making me feel angry. To me, it's like this obsession with image that is such a toxic quality of the community that we're from and the family that we're from.
这份列表仍然让我感到难过。但那是我开始对它感到生气的时候。对我来说，这就像是对形象的执着，这是我们社区和家庭的一种有毒品质。
We may have looked good from the outside, but alcoholism and mental illness run in our family and were a big part of my childhood. You don't need to know the specifics. Just know that it was chaos. And not even Mr. Golden Child was spared from it.
从外面看我们可能很好，但酗酒和精神疾病在我们家族中很常见，是我童年的很大一部分。你不需要知道细节。只需要知道当时一片混乱。连“黄金模范生”也没能幸免。
But where I struggled and flailed and totally embodied all that chaos, Mike tried to contain it, to impose order on it, to fix it by being perfect. And that's what the list is, a manifestation of his drive to be perfect. That's how Pat sees it, anyway.
但在我挣扎、挥霍并完全体现了所有混乱的时候，麦克试图抑制它，强加秩序，试图通过完美来修正它。这就是那个列表，他追求完美的动力表现。反正帕特是这么看的。
It's painful for me, the list, because it's about what trauma did to Mike. And now these adults are waving it around like it was some sort of thing to be proud of with him. And there's a lot of things that I'm very proud of that he did. I'd rather those things be remembered than this insane pressure that he put on himself.
这份列表对我来说很痛苦，因为它是关于创伤对麦克做了什么。现在这些成年人把它挥舞得好像它是值得为他自豪的东西。他所做的很多事情我都非常自豪。我宁愿记住那些事情，而不是这种他施加给自己的疯狂压力。
What do you wish he was remembered for? What are the things you want him remembered for?
你希望他因为什么而被记住？你想要他被记住的事情是什么？
I think just who he was, really. There's really nothing to be ashamed of. But he wasn't this model person in school. We sold weed together. We provided pretty much the entire football team with weed. We had a little business thing going on. It was funny. It wasn't bad. It was funny. It's also just the truth. Whether it's funny or not funny, I just want the truth remembered.
我觉得就是他本人，真的。真的没什么好羞耻的。但他不是学校里的那种模范人物。我们一起卖大麻。我们基本上给整个橄榄球队提供了大麻。我们有点小生意。这很有趣。它并不坏。它很有趣。这也是事实。无论有趣与否，我只是想让事实被记住。
I don't want to have to deal with these fake stories about Mike. When I was at the banquet, they gave a check to the kid that won his award. And I'm with dad. And the kid comes up. And dad says to him, he goes, make sure you spend this on other people. That's what Mike would have done. And I look at the kid--
我不想处理这些关于麦克的虚假故事。我在宴会上时，他们把支票给了一个赢得他奖项的孩子。我和爸爸在一起。孩子走了上来。爸爸对他说，他说，确保你把它花在别人身上。麦克会那么做的。我看着那个孩子——
That's not what he would have done.
他不会那么做。
That's what I said. And I looked at dad and I go, who are you talking about? You talking about Mike? And then I look at the kid and I'm just like, dude, my brother would have spent this on the dumbest shit, all right?
这就是我说的。我看着爸爸说，你在说谁？你在说麦克？然后我看着那个孩子说，哥们，我兄弟会把它花在最烂的事情上，好吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
You do whatever you want with that money, kid. Go have fun.
随你怎么处理那些钱，孩子。去玩个痛快吧。
Really? You said that?
真的吗？你这么说了？
Yeah. He would have.
是的。他会那么做的。
He would have blown that money. He was greedy--
他会把那些钱挥霍掉。他很贪婪——
He was terrible with money.
他对钱很糟糕。
--and also bad with money, yeah.
——而且也不擅长理财，是的。
He would buy a $400 pair of sunglasses and then accidentally leave them on top of a car and lose them.
他会买一副400美元的墨镜，然后不小心把它落在车顶上弄丢了。
Didn't he put a subwoofer in his car too, at one point?
他不是还在车里装过低音炮吗，有一次？
The subwoofer was awesome, OK? The subwoofer was such a deal and perfectly for the hatchback. And Dad put his foot down--
那个低音炮很棒，好吗？那个低音炮买得很值，非常适合掀背车。然后爸爸下了禁令——
The list doesn't just leave out Mike's flaws. It also misses, really, the best stuff about him. He was warm, generous, extremely goofy.
列表不仅忽略了麦克的缺点。它也确实错过了关于他最好的东西。他温暖、慷慨，非常滑稽。
He was curious. And that was a really good quality that he had. He found people really interesting. So he liked to listen.
他很好奇。这是他真正拥有的一个很好的品质。他觉得人们很有趣。所以他喜欢倾听。
Be curious would be a good one to be on here.
“保持好奇”会是一个很好的条目。
Yeah. Kids from my grade, they come up to me and they tell me stories about Mike, when they started on the football team and they felt they didn't belong there. Because the older kids were dicks. And they said my brother would come around and he would comfort them and he would encourage them.
是的。我们年级的孩子找到我，跟我讲关于麦克的故事，当他们刚进橄榄球队觉得不属于那里时。因为高年级的孩子很混蛋。他们说我兄弟会过来安慰他们并鼓励他们。
And then I remember hearing from Ally Opromolla. And she said when they were dating, Mike had a great relationship with her grandmother. And he would watch TV with her grandmother. I think it was like game shows or something. Maybe it was Wheel of Fortune.
我还记得听艾莉·奥普罗莫拉（Ally Opromolla）说起。她说他们约会时，麦克和她的祖母关系很好。他会陪她祖母看电视。我想是游戏节目之类的。也许是《幸运轮》。
And he would just watch TV with her. And they would shoot the shit. Yeah, those are the stories that I'm proud of. Because they are a reflection of who he was. He was a good guy that people enjoyed. And that's the kind of stuff I want to remember.
他会陪她看电视。他们会瞎扯淡。是的，那些是我自豪的故事。因为它们反映了他是谁。他是个大家都很喜欢的好人。这就是我想记住的那种事情。
Last year, Pat wrote to the football coach at our high school and asked him to use the list to spread awareness about suicide. He got him to add a line to the bottom of it. It says, "There is great strength in vulnerability, as it takes courage to push through the fear and share one's true self with others."
去年，帕特写信给我们高中的橄榄球教练，请他利用这份列表传播关于自杀的意识。他让他加了一行字在底部。上面写着：“脆弱中蕴含着巨大的力量，因为敢于克服恐惧并与他人分享真实的自己需要勇气。”
Recently, after my wife and I moved into our new apartment, I made a decision to hang up the list again. It's in my home office. Now I'm the one looking at it every day. And I don't resent it anymore.
最近，我和我妻子搬进新公寓后，我决定再次把这份列表挂起来。它就在我的家庭办公室里。现在是我每天看着它。我不再怨恨它了。
Maybe it still makes me feel a little weird, OK? But I see it for what it is. I don't feel judged by it. And some of the lists, I'm genuinely down with. Create unity is a beautiful idea. It reminds me of the best of Mike. But mostly, I just like looking at my brother's handwriting.
也许它仍然让我感觉有点奇怪，好吗？但我看到了它的本质。我不再觉得被它评判了。而且有些列表内容，我确实是真心赞同的。“创造团结”是一个美好的想法。它让我想起麦克最好的一面。但主要是，我只是喜欢看着我兄弟的笔迹。
John Fecile. He's a Senior Producer at the show Snap Judgment. His story was produced by Sean Cole.
约翰·费西尔。他是Snap Judgment节目的高级制作人。他的故事由肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）制作。
Coming up, over a hundred dogs and one giant bear, and its list of enemies. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一百多只狗和一只巨大的熊，以及它的敌人列表。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- Lists! How they tame the chaos of the world.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——列表！它们如何驯服世界的混乱。
This list is all the dogs in my dog's life, kind of segmented by different criteria.
这个列表是我狗的生活中所有的狗，按不同的标准分类。
This is Bobby Sherwood, who's friends with one of our producers here, Chris Benderev. And he's showing Chris a lists that he keeps on his phone of neighborhood dogs.
这是鲍比·舍伍德（Bobby Sherwood），他与我们的一位制片人克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）是朋友。他正在向克里斯展示他手机里保留的社区狗狗列表。
We've got Lunchbox, who's a cream Scottie with a turquoise vest. We've got Virgil, who is some kind of doodle dog. But I said, "little fried chicken dog." And the owner looks like my friend Otto.
我们有Lunchbox，一只穿着绿松石色背心的奶油色苏格兰梗。我们有Virgil，某种涂鸦狗。但我叫它“小炸鸡狗”。主人看起来像我的朋友奥托。
Wait, what is little fried chicken dog?
等等，什么是小炸鸡狗？
Some doodles have tight, curly brown hair fur. And it looks exactly like fried chicken. So this dog literally looks like a walking piece of fried chicken.
有些涂鸦狗有又紧又卷的棕色毛发。看起来完全像炸鸡。所以这只狗看起来就像一只行走的炸鸡。
Bobby keeps this list because there are so many dogs where he lives. There are 130 dogs on this list. And his memory isn't always the greatest. And he's convinced that people can tell if you don't know their dog's name and you're faking it by saying things like--
鲍比保留这个列表是因为他住的地方狗太多了。这个列表上有130只狗。他的记忆力不总是最好的。他确信如果他不记得狗的名字并假装说些话，人们是能看出来的，比如——
How's he or she doing today? Or how's your puppy? You got to find--
他或她今天过得怎么样？或者你的小狗怎么样？你必须找到——
And he is not into the potential awkwardness of that. OK, just for context, he does have a list of people like this too, to remember the spouses of friends and coworkers that he's met just once, and people's kids. But the dog list, he also finds it helpful to rank all the dogs. So his dog Chewy's favorites are at the top. And his least favorites are at the bottom.
他不喜欢那种潜在的尴尬。好了，只是为了背景说明，他也有这样一个人的列表，为了记住他只见过一次的朋友和同事的配偶，以及人们的孩子。但关于狗的列表，他也觉得给所有的狗排序很有帮助。所以他的狗Chewy的最爱在顶部。最不喜欢的在底部。
There are some dogs that bully Chewy, so we throw them at the bottom of the list. And then we know, hey, this one is [BLEEP] who beats up Chewy. You might want to bleep that name.
有些狗欺负Chewy，所以我们把它们扔到列表底部。然后我们就知道，嘿，这就是那个[哔]它欺负Chewy。你可能想把那个名字消音。
To see how this works in practice, Chris followed Bobby to the dog park. And it doesn't take long before they get into a list-needing situation.
为了看看这在实践中如何运作，克里斯跟着鲍比去了狗公园。没过多久，他们就进入了一个需要列表的情况。
I definitely think I recognize that dog, the tall doodle over there.
我肯定我觉得我认得那只狗，那边那只高大的涂鸦狗。
Walk me through what you're doing.
告诉我你在做什么。
So I see a big boy I'm sure Chewy's run into at this dog park before. Let me see. Scrolling.
所以我看到了一个大块头，我确信Chewy在狗公园里遇见过它。让我看看。滚动。
He scrolls down the list on his phone until he gets to the dog park section, searching for a dog with a description--
他滚动手机上的列表直到狗公园部分，搜索一只描述为——
Shaggy brown doodle? Yeah. I don't know.
毛茸茸的棕色涂鸦狗？是的。我不知道。
He finds nothing. He'll have to add that one to the list. Bobby has no idea how other dog owners do it, keep track of all the dogs, though I think it's entirely possible that other people are no better with the names than he is. And they just don't care.
他一无所获。他得把那个加到列表里。鲍比不知道其他狗主人是怎么做的，怎么追踪所有的狗，尽管我认为其他人可能和名字一样记不住。他们只是不在乎。
Yeah, he's a cutie.
是的，它很可爱。
When he and Chris get back to the house, they run into a neighbor's dog who somehow wasn't on the list yet.
当他和克里斯回到家时，他们遇到了一只邻居的狗，它不知怎么还没在列表上。
I'm going to add it to the list, though. I've actually bumped into that dog many times. And he always says he's friendly. And it's like, yeah, I know. We've met like 10 times.
不过我会把它加到列表里的。我其实遇见过那只狗很多次。他总是说很友好。就像是，是的，我知道。我们遇见过大概10次了。
Do you think he doesn't remember you?
你觉得他不记得你吗？
I don't know. I don't know. That guy needs a list though, you know?
我不知道。我不知道。但那个人需要一个列表，你知道吗？
Act 2, "Target List." There's some lists you definitely do not want to be on. This past Thanksgiving, M had people come stay with them at a house they affectionately call the dacha because it's out of the city and they're Russian. That's just the word Russians use.
第二幕，“目标列表”。有些列表你绝对不想出现在上面。去年感恩节，M有客人住在他们亲切地称为“达恰”（dacha）的房子里，因为这在城外，他们是俄罗斯人。这就是俄罗斯人用的词。
We totally call it the dacha.
我们完全叫它达恰。
M is M. Gessen. They write about Russia for The New Yorker and in books. And the day after Thanksgiving, two of their guests left for some other celebration. And a bunch of the remaining guests, four or five people, went on a hike, a pretty vertical one, actually, up a nearby mountain. So they get to a spot way up high.
M是M·格森（M. Gessen）。他们为《纽约客》撰写关于俄罗斯的文章和书籍。感恩节后的第二天，两位客人去了其他庆祝活动。剩下的一些客人，四五个人，去远足了，实际上是一座相当垂直的山，去附近的一座山。他们到达了一个很高的地方。
Yeah, it's an overlook point. It's pretty tiny. We're all standing pretty close together, looking out at the Catskills and the little town where we live. And then two of us pulled out our phones.
是的，这是一个瞭望点。很小。我们都站得很近，望着卡茨基尔山脉和我们居住的小镇。然后我们两个拿出了手机。
As one does. How much nature can you take?
就像人们通常做的那样。你能受得了多少自然风光？
And both of us saw a news item that one of the friends who had left that morning had been declared a foreign agent.
我们俩都看到一条新闻，那天早上离开的一位朋友被宣布为外国代理人。
Foreign agent, in other words, the Russian government just put him on an official list of people that it is not very fond of. Foreign agent is not a good thing.
外国代理人，换句话说，俄罗斯政府刚把他列入了官方的、不太喜欢的个人列表。外国代理人不是什么好东西。
And this is something that the Russian government does almost every Friday.
这是俄罗斯政府几乎每个星期五都会做的事情。
They put out a list of foreign agents?
他们发布一份外国代理人名单？
Right. It's like this weird, weird spectator sport to see who is now a foreign agent.
对。这就像是一场奇怪、奇怪的观赛运动，看看谁现在成了外国代理人。
It's weird. It's like a sinister version of when Oscar nominations come out or something, you know?
很奇怪。这就像是奥斯卡提名出炉时的某种阴险版本，你知道吗？
Actually, that's not a bad simile. Because when Oscar nominations come out, then you have to wonder, what's going to be the outcome for any one of these?
实际上，那个比喻不错。因为当奥斯卡提名出炉时，你必须怀疑，其中任何一个人的结果会是什么？
Yeah.
是的。
And with foreign agents, it's a little bit like that. Part of being on the list of foreign agents is that you're put on notice. You're on our radar. We may launch a criminal case against you, which has much harsher consequences.
对于外国代理人，有点像那样。成为外国代理人列表的一部分意味着你被通知了。你在我们的雷达上。我们可能会对你发起刑事案件，这有更严厉的后果。
Oh, you can graduate from this list to worse lists?
噢，你可以从这个列表毕业到更糟的列表？
Yes, they end up on other lists, like the wanted list. Or somebody just stays a foreign agent indefinitely. But it's extremely unpleasant. It sort of reconfigures your world.
是的，他们最终会出现在其他列表上，比如通缉名单。或者某人只是无限期地保持外国代理人身份。但这极其令人不快。它某种程度上重构了你的世界。
So they're out on this mountain. M and one of the other Russians reads this on their phones, that their friend who they just had Thanksgiving dinner with the night before is now a foreign agent.
所以他们在山上。M和另一位俄罗斯人在手机上读到这个消息，他们前一天晚上刚一起吃过感恩节晚餐的朋友现在成了外国代理人。
So we both say his last name, Venyavkin. And this is something that's actually happened before between the two of us, where we just take out our phones on a Friday, see a name, and say the name. Because you don't have to say, Venyavkin has been named a foreign agent, because we know it's Friday.
所以我们俩都说出他的姓，Venyavkin。这实际上是我们俩之间发生过的事情，我们只是在星期五拿出手机，看到一个名字，然后说出那个名字。因为你不需要说，Venyavkin被命名为外国代理人，因为我们知道那是星期五。
M says Russia is now in an age of lists. It started when Vladimir Putin created the list of foreign agents when he took the presidency for a second time in 2012. And he started clamping down on dissent. At first, it was just organizations on the foreign agents list-- human rights groups, media outfits.
M说俄罗斯现在处于列表时代。这始于弗拉基米尔·普京在2012年第二次就任总统时创建了外国代理人列表。他开始打击异议。起初，只有组织在外国代理人列表上——人权团体、媒体机构。
And then, three and a half years ago, they started adding the names of people to the list. Russia actually modeled its foreign agent law on an American foreign agent law. It dates to the 1930s. One key difference between the two laws, among many, in America, to be a foreign agent, you actually have to be working for or acting on behalf of a foreign government organization.
然后，三年半前，他们开始在列表上增加人的名字。俄罗斯实际上是以美国外国代理人法为蓝本制定的外国代理人法。它追溯到20世纪30年代。两项法律之间的关键区别之一，在许多区别中，在美国，要成为外国代理人，你实际上必须为外国政府组织工作或代表其行事。
And you put yourself on the list. You register as a foreign agent. In Russia, the government just puts you on a list, calls you a foreign agent, and voila, you are one. M says this list and the way the Putin government has been using it are typical of the way he's operating these days.
而且你自己把自己列入名单。你注册为外国代理人。在俄罗斯，政府直接把你列入名单，称你为外国代理人，瞧，你就是了。M说这个列表以及普京政府使用它的方式，是他们这些天操作方式的典型。
It's very bureaucratic. And so all these lists have weird nomenclatures. It's foreign agents list or undesirable organizations or unfriendly countries. So the United States, for example, is an unfriendly country to Russia.
非常官僚。所以所有这些列表都有奇怪的命名法。它是外国代理人列表、不可取组织或不友好国家。所以美国，例如，对俄罗斯来说是一个不友好国家。
Right.
对。
What they mean is mortal enemy.
他们的意思是死敌。
It's so weird that they feel compelled to divide off the world into the friendly countries and unfriendly countries, that they actually have to write it down on a list.
他们觉得有必要把世界划分为友好国家和不友好国家，以至于他们实际上必须把它写在列表上，这太奇怪了。
That's a great point. It's a combination of a country that has the ideology of a fortress under siege and a country that has a deeply, deeply bureaucratic self-understanding. So everything has to be somehow classified and put down on paper or in an Excel table. This resurgent totalitarianism in Russia, it's really focused on the bureaucracy. The bureaucracy is its heart, its core. And that's why lists are so important.
这是一个很好的点。这是具有被围困堡垒意识形态的国家和具有深刻官僚自我理解的国家的结合。所以一切都必须以某种方式分类并记录在纸上或Excel表格中。这种俄罗斯复苏的极权主义，它确实专注于官僚机构。官僚机构是它的心脏，它的核心。这就是为什么列表如此重要。
Are you on this list?
你在名单上吗？
I'm not. I'm on a different list, a worse list.
我不在。我在另一个列表上，一个更糟的列表。
What list is that?
那个列表是什么？
I'm on the wanted list, because there's a criminal case against me.
我在通缉名单上，因为有一个针对我的刑事案件。
M says that being put on one of these lists throws you out of the normal world and into this weird, undefined limbo or purgatory, where things are different and more worrisome. Because it's unclear what's going to happen next. What is clear is that it's a permanent status change.
M说被列入这些列表之一会把你从正常世界扔进这个奇怪的、未定义的边缘或炼狱，那里的事情是不同的，更令人担忧。因为不清楚接下来会发生什么。清楚的是，这是一个永久性的状态改变。
Our program today is about lists. And as part of that, we wanted to hear from people who are on a target list, about what it's like to live that disquieting life. And M agreed to reach out to some to talk about it and talk especially about what it's like to be on the foreign agent list.
我们今天的节目是关于列表的。作为其中的一部分，我们想听听那些在目标名单上的人，了解过那种令人不安的生活是什么感觉。M同意联系一些人来谈论这一点，特别是谈论作为外国代理人列表上的感觉。
The foreign agent list is interesting, because being on that list really can mean such a wide range of things. Maybe it'll be nothing. Or maybe things will get a lot worse. Here's what M put together.
外国代理人列表很有趣，因为出现在名单上确实意味着非常广泛的事情。也许什么都不会发生。或者也许事情会变得更糟。这是M整理的内容。
I've been watching the foreign agent list grow for a few years. It's now about 400 people, most of them living outside of Russia. And I probably know half of them. That's one reason I've been sort of obsessed with the list. It's a day that changes your life.
我一直在看着外国代理人列表增长几年了。现在大约有400人，他们大多数住在俄罗斯境外。我可能认识他们的一半。这是我有点痴迷于列表的一个原因。那是一个改变你一生的日子。
I was cutting the turkey. And I believe that I was in the midst of cutting my fourth turkey in a row.
我当时正在切火鸡。我相信我正在切连续第四只火鸡。
This is Ilya, my friend who was put on the list the Friday after Thanksgiving.
这是伊利亚（Ilya），我的朋友，感恩节后的星期五被列入名单。
Fourth turkey that weekend or fourth turkey that day?
那个周末第四只火鸡还是那天第四只火鸡？
Probably that weekend. And then I saw my wife coming to me. And I realized that she was pale. And I realized that something happened. And then she told me that I was declared a foreign agent.
可能是那个周末。然后我看到我的妻子向我走来。我意识到她脸色苍白。我意识到发生了什么。然后她告诉我，我被宣布为外国代理人。
Here's Galina Arapova's version of the experience of finding out she was on the list. She's a media lawyer who was representing journalists who had been put on the list. Then she was branded a foreign agent herself. She was the first lawyer on the list. She found out when a reporter called to ask her about the implications.
这是加琳娜·阿拉波娃（Galina Arapova）发现自己在名单上的经验版本。她是一位媒体律师，代表着那些被列入名单的记者。然后她自己也被贴上了外国代理人的标签。她是名单上的第一位律师。她发现是因为一名记者打电话问她关于其影响的问题。
Believe it or not, for the first few seconds, I didn't realize that he is actually saying to me that my name appeared on the list. I thought that he was asking me to provide a comment like what would happen, what if you appear on the list, how that would affect your life. And then I just realized that it's actually not a hypothetical, that he's actually informing me that my name is on the list.
信不信由你，前几秒钟，我没意识到他实际上是在告诉我我的名字出现在名单上。我还以为他在请求我提供评论，比如会发生什么，如果你出现在名单上会怎样，那会如何影响你的生活。然后我才意识到，这实际上不是一个假设，他实际上是在通知我我的名字在名单上。
Being put on the foreign agent list has consequences regardless of where the person lives. And once the Russian government names you a foreign agent, you face a bunch of choices. Because there are all sorts of special rules that apply to foreign agents. And you have to decide whether you're going to comply.
无论人住在哪里，被列入外国代理人名单都会有后果。一旦俄罗斯政府把你命名为外国代理人，你就面临一系列选择。因为有各种各样的特殊规则适用于外国代理人。你必须决定是否要遵守。
One rule, every time you communicate anything publicly or semi-publicly in the media or in social media or in a dating app even, you have to warn people that they're dealing with a foreign agent. There's a special disclaimer you have to use in extra large type.
一条规则，每次你在媒体或社交媒体、甚至约会应用中公开或半公开地交流任何信息时，你必须警告人们他们正在与外国代理人打交道。你必须使用一个特殊的免责声明，且使用超大字号。
It's huge. It has to be in font, in letters twice bigger than the main text.
很大。它必须是那种字体，字母比主文本大两倍。
Do you remember the exact words? You can say them in Russian if you want.
你还记得确切的词吗？如果你愿意，你可以用俄语说。
Yes. [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
是的。[俄语]
The disclaimer says, this message or information was created and/or disseminated by a foreign agent, non-governmental organization.
免责声明说，此消息或信息是由外国代理人、非政府组织创建和/或传播的。
Which is quite a big paragraph, considering the size. In social media, it would be like in Caps Lock.
考虑到尺寸，这是一个相当大的段落。在社交媒体上，它就像大写锁定一样。
It's an all caps?
它是全大写吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And it gets more Byzantine. A person who has been put on the list must create a corporation. And the corporation, in the eyes of the state, is you. And you are the corporation.
而且变得更加拜占庭式。一个被列入名单的人必须创建一个公司。而在国家眼中，公司就是你。而你就是公司。
This corporation has to file quarterly financial reports detailing the income you make and the money you spend, submit to an annual audit, and also post regular reports of your activities, whatever that means, on the internet, or submit them to the media for publication. The paperwork has to be perfect every time, but the rules are vague.
这个公司必须提交季度财务报告，详细说明你的收入和支出，接受年度审计，还需要在互联网上定期发布你的活动报告（无论那意味着什么），或者提交给媒体出版。文书工作每次都必须完美，但规则很模糊。
So you can make mistakes easily. And then if you made a mistake, here, government comes with a fine. First fine, second fine, and then criminal case. So it's all made as a big trap. And all these games around it, it's like Tom and Jerry game. They are just running after us and we're trying to run away, trying to still do the job.
所以你可以很容易犯错。然后如果你犯了错，政府就带着罚款来了。第一次罚款，第二次罚款，然后是刑事案件。所以这一切被制造为一个巨大的陷阱。围绕它的所有游戏，就像汤姆和杰瑞的游戏。他们只是在我们身后奔跑，我们试图逃跑，同时仍试图完成工作。
Galina follows the rules. Most of her clients do, even if they're living outside of Russia. Because everyone has someone or something left behind-- family members that the authorities can decide to harass, property the authorities can seize.
加琳娜遵守规则。她的大多数客户也遵守，即使他们住在俄罗斯境外。因为每个人都有人或东西留在后面——当局可以决定骚扰的家人，当局可以没收的财产。
My friend Karen decided not to follow the rules. He'd left Russia right after the full-scale invasion of Ukraine. And a couple of months later, his name popped up on the list. Like everyone, he still had a million things tying him to Russia.
我的朋友卡伦（Karen）决定不遵守规则。他在俄罗斯全面入侵乌克兰后立即离开了俄罗斯。几个月后，他的名字出现在名单上。像每个人一样，他仍然有数百万件事情与俄罗斯紧密相连。
So I knew that I'm not going to play by those rules. And I decided to just get rid of everything I had back there, including my apartment.
所以我知道我不打算按照那些规则玩。我决定卖掉我在那里拥有的一切，包括我的公寓。
So you were thinking that now that you were on this list of foreign agents, your property in Russia was in danger and you should basically take money out of the country?
所以你在想，既然你在外国代理人名单上，你在俄罗斯的财产就处于危险之中，你基本上应该把钱转出国外？
Yes.
是的。
What did that feel like?
那感觉像什么？
It felt like nothing. I told myself, we don't go there. I mean, in that infinite depth of feelings about your country and everybody who you left there and stuff, it can drive you crazy. So I just didn't feel anything.
感觉什么都没有。我告诉自己，我们不去那里。我是说，关于你的国家和你留在那里的人以及其他事物的无限深情中，它可以让你发疯。所以我只是什么也没感觉到。
A little over a year later, Karen found out that he was on another list, the list of extremists and terrorists. This was, you could say, an upgrade. It meant that the Russian state froze whatever assets he still had in Russia. So he'd been smart to sell his apartment.
一年多一点后，卡伦发现他在另一个列表上，即极端分子和恐怖分子名单。这你可以说是升级。这意味着俄罗斯国家冻结了他在俄罗斯仍拥有的任何资产。所以他卖掉公寓是很聪明的。
But being on this list also meant they'd opened a criminal case against him. Just to make this clear, he hadn't been informed that there was a case against him. Karen had to hire a lawyer to figure out what he was charged with and which prosecutor was charging him. Karen and I have talked about this weird process of having to find your own case, because there's also a criminal case against me in Russia.
但出现在这个名单上也意味着他们对他开启了刑事案件。为了说清楚，他没有被通知针对他有一个案件。卡伦不得不雇佣一名律师来弄清楚他被指控什么，以及哪位检察官在指控他。卡伦和我谈过这种必须找到你自己案件的奇怪过程，因为在俄罗斯也有一个针对我的刑事案件。
I found out about it from articles in Russian government media. And then my name appeared on the wanted list. In the hierarchy of lists, the wanted list is probably the worst-- that we know about anyway. I've now been arrested in absentia, and in the next few months, a Moscow court is going to sentence me to 7 or 8 or 9 years in prison.
我从俄罗斯政府媒体的文章中发现了它。然后我的名字出现在通缉名单上。在列表层级中，通缉名单可能是最糟糕的——我们所知的 anyway。我现已被缺席逮捕，在接下来的几个月里，莫斯科法院将判处我7或8或9年监禁。
It took my lawyer two months to find the case against me for, quote, "spreading false information about the Russian military." Karen said I was lucky. It took his lawyer six months to find his case. Karen's crime? Years ago, Karen donated money to Alexei Navalny's anti-corruption foundation. Navalny is the Russian politician who died in an Arctic prison earlier this year.
我的律师花了两个月才找到针对我引用“传播关于俄罗斯军队的虚假信息”的案件。卡伦说我很幸运。他的律师花了六个月才找到他的案件。卡伦的罪行？几年前，卡伦向阿列克谢·纳瓦利内的反腐败基金会捐了款。纳瓦利内是今年早些时候在北极监狱中去世的俄罗斯政治家。
And when did you give money to the Navalny organization? Do you remember?
你什么时候给纳瓦利内组织捐钱的？你还记得吗？
Well, for years. And that, of course, it was long before they labeled Navalny Foundation as illegal or extremist or anything else. I was one of thousands of people, I believe, who supported Navalny and his foundation.
嗯，好几年了。当然，那是在他们将纳瓦利内基金会标记为非法或极端分子或其他任何东西之前很久。我相信我是成千上万支持纳瓦利内及其基金会的人之一。
Do you have any idea how much money you gave them?
你知道你给了他们多少钱吗？
Not that much. I believe a few hundred dollars total.
没那么多。我相信总共几百美元。
By the way, Alexei Navalny was also on the list of extremists and terrorists. He still is on that list, because the authorities say they haven't received proper documentation of his death.
顺便说一下，阿列克谢·纳瓦利内也在极端分子和恐怖分子名单上。他仍然在那个名单上，因为当局说他们没有收到他死亡的适当文件。
Any contact with Russian state recently resembles more and more contact with hooligans back in elementary or middle school.
任何与俄罗斯国家的近期接触越来越像与小学或中学里的流氓接触。
Bullies?
恶霸？
Yeah, like with bullies. This is a feeling that they are very strong, very hostile, and very-- [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
是的，像恶霸。这是一种感觉，他们非常强大，非常敌对，而且非常—— [俄语]
Small minded?
心胸狭窄？
Yeah, strong, hostile, and small-minded, sort of feeling that they are like big, angry animal who is trying to attack you when they're scared of you, and who can kill you because they're scared of you.
是的，强大，敌对，心胸狭窄，某种感觉他们就像一只大而愤怒的动物，当你害怕他们时他们试图攻击你，并且因为他们害怕你而可能杀了你。
Let's just call this animal what it is. You're describing a bear, a Russian bear.
让我们直接称呼这只动物的本质吧。你描述的是一只熊，一只俄罗斯熊。
Yeah, that's such a cliche. Come on.
是的，那真是个陈词滥调。得了吧。
With the Russian bear on your heels, you have to watch your step. If you're going to travel, you have to ask, is it safe? Can I go there? Ilya Krasilschik, a different Ilya, now divides all the countries in the world into three categories.
有俄罗斯熊在你的脚后跟，你必须小心你的脚步。如果你要旅行，你必须问，安全吗？我可以去那里吗？伊利亚·克拉西尔希克（Ilya Krasilschik），另一个伊利亚，现在把世界上所有的国家分为三类。
Can't go, maybe can't go, can go with consequences.
不能去，可能不能去，可以去但有后果。
Can go with consequences really means don't go. You don't want the consequences. Ilya started a media outlet called HelpDesk, which reports on the war in Ukraine and helps Ukrainians flee the fighting. In the eyes of the Russian state, he has been a criminal for more than two years for posting about war crimes in Bucha.
可以去但有后果实际上意味着不要去。你不想面对后果。伊利亚创办了一家名为HelpDesk的媒体，报道乌克兰战争并帮助乌克兰人逃离战斗。在俄罗斯国家眼中，他已经成为罪犯两年多了，因为发布关于布查战争罪行的报道。
I haven't been a criminal for as long as Ilya has, but I've also learned there's a whole convoluted science to it. Some countries will extradite people to Russia, some countries might. And then there's Interpol, the International police, which Russia tries to use to have people detained and sometimes extradited. The planning that goes into traveling to other countries can get very granular.
虽然我作为罪犯的时间没伊利亚那么长，但我也学到了一整套复杂的科学。有些国家会将人引渡到俄罗斯，有些国家可能。还有国际刑警组织，即国际警察，俄罗斯试图利用它来让人被拘留，有时甚至被引渡。前往其他国家的规划可以变得非常细致。
Sometimes it's not about where you go, but about which company you're flying. And this is really difficult. Because, for example, Turkish Airlines, if something will happen, they can land in Russia. Because they have this airport as the Plan B airport. But you need to call every airline and ask them for every route. And I think somebody should do this.
有时它不在于你去哪里，而在于你搭乘哪家航空公司。这真的很难。因为，例如，土耳其航空公司，如果发生什么事，他们可以降落在俄罗斯。因为他们有这个机场作为B计划机场。但你需要打电话给每家航空公司询问每条航线。我认为有人应该这样做。
You could easily spend all your time, your entire life perfecting the act, being Jerry who keeps evading Tom.
你可以很容易地花费你所有的时间，你的一生来完善这个行为，像不断躲避汤姆的杰瑞。
So it's absurd. And absurd should be fun. I don't know, like Kafka, yeah? Kafka is funny in some way, but it's also awful.
所以这很荒谬。而荒谬应该很有趣。我不知道，像卡夫卡，是吗？卡夫卡在某种程度上很有趣，但它也很糟糕。
It used to be, when a friend was named a foreign agent, I would send them a note saying, proud to know you, like it was some sort of recognition. At some point, that stopped feeling right. I didn't feel proud, not when my friends were put on a list and not when I landed on Russia's wanted list.
过去，当一位朋友被命名为外国代理人时，我会给他们写张条子，上面写着“为你感到骄傲”，就像这是一种认可一样。在某个时刻，那感觉不对了。我没感到骄傲，不是当我的朋友被列入名单时，也不是当我出现在俄罗斯的通缉名单上时。
When that happened, my friend Ilya, the one who was carving the turkeys at Thanksgiving, texted me, "I'm not sure what the protocol is. Do I congratulate you or express condolences?" I felt sad.
当那发生时，我的朋友伊利亚，那个感恩节正在切火鸡的人，给我发短信说：“我不确定协议是什么。我是该祝贺你还是表示哀悼？”我感到难过。
Help me understand the sadness. Because when I found out that there was a criminal case against me, and then later when I found out that I was arrested in absentia, in a sense, intellectually, it's almost exciting. And as people often say, it's a sort of recognition.
帮我理解这种悲伤。因为当我发现针对我有一个刑事案件时，后来当我发现我被缺席逮捕时，在某种意义上，从智力上讲，这几乎令人兴奋。而且正如人们常说的那样，这是一种认可。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
And I felt profoundly sad. I felt like I was carrying around another burden that hadn't been there before. What is it?
而且我感到深深的悲伤。我感觉自己背负着另一个以前不存在的负担。它是什么？
Oh, that's a good one. If I'm telling you something rude, if I'm telling you I hate you, it's OK to be sad about that. Because it's sad that someone hates me. And when I'm saying that, well, I'm honored by that or they're stupid, I feel that this reaction's just shielding you from the sadness and tragedy of that.
噢，那是个好问题。如果我在告诉你什么粗鲁的事情，如果我在告诉你我讨厌你，为那感到难过是可以的。因为它很悲伤，有人讨厌我。而当我那样说时，嗯，我感到荣幸或他们很愚蠢，我觉得这种反应只是在保护你免受那份悲伤和悲剧。
The elephant in the room of my sadness is that being considered a criminal by the Russian state means I'll never be able to go home again, not even if there is a change of regime. I doubt that the first, second, or even third thing they're going to do after Putin is purge all the lists. So like the vast majority of Russians who are on these lists, I'm in exile for life.
我悲伤中不可言说的真相是，被俄罗斯国家视为罪犯意味着我永远无法回家，即使政权更迭了也无法回家。我怀疑普京之后他们要做的第一、第二甚至第三件事会是清洗所有列表。所以像大多数在这些列表上的俄罗斯人一样，我终身流亡。
For many of us who live outside of Russia, this business of being on lists is really akin to having a troublesome chronic illness. You keep tabs on it. You modify your behavior as necessary. You hope it doesn't kill you. But other than that, you live a relatively normal, American, or German or Dutch life.
对于我们许多住在俄罗斯境外的人来说，被列入列表这件事确实类似于患上了一种令人烦恼的慢性病。你关注它。你根据需要修改你的行为。你希望它不会杀死你。但除此之外，你过着相对正常的美国、德国或荷兰生活。
For those who are still in Russia, though, the condition can be much more serious. Zoya is one such person. Zoya is not her real name. She's an LGBT activist. And in November of last year, the Russian Supreme Court declared the, quote, "international LGBT movement was an extremist organization."
然而对于那些仍在俄罗斯的人来说，情况可能要严重得多。卓雅（Zoya）就是这样一个人。卓雅不是她的真名。她是一位LGBT活动家。去年11月，俄罗斯最高法院宣布所谓的“国际LGBT运动是一个极端主义组织”。
Zoya had been put on lists even before that, though, internal lists circulated within government agencies. These lists aren't meant to be public, but there is an illicit service that will search different internal lists and databases and send you what they find-- like a Freedom of Information Act request, but fast, unredacted, and for sale.
在此之前，卓雅就已经被列入名单了，那是政府机构内部流通的内部名单。这些名单本不该公开，但有一种非法服务可以搜索不同的内部名单和数据库并发送你发现的内容——就像信息自由法案的请求，但很快，未经删改，且可以买卖。
You can just pay a very small amount, like $30, and download everything what they have on you, including these informal lists that police create for their work. You will be able to see how this regime see you, what do they have on you. Do they follow your flights? It's enough information.
你可以只支付很少的费用，比如30美元，下载他们拥有关于你的一切，包括警察为工作创建的这些非正式列表。你将能够看到这个政权如何看你，他们拥有关于你什么。他们追踪你的航班吗？信息足够了。
And what you get is an Excel document or PDF?
你得到的是Excel文档还是PDF？
PDF.
PDF。
PDF?
PDF？
PDF Document.
PDF文档。
On the PDF, the lists you're on are marked in red. So her PDF said extremism and terrorism in red. But again, this wasn't the public list of extremists and terrorists.
在PDF上，你在名单上的列表被标记为红色。所以她的PDF用红色标记了极端主义和恐怖主义。但同样，这不是公开的极端分子和恐怖分子名单。
Yeah, it's two different lists. If it's possible, I will say it to you in Russian.
是的，这是两个不同的列表。如果可能的话，我用俄语告诉你。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语]
If you can translate it.
如果你能翻译的话。
So the reason you wanted to say it in Russian is not because you can't translate it, but because the word doesn't exist.
所以你用俄语说是为了那个词不存在，而不是因为你不能翻译它。
Yeah.
是的。
Right? So it's like, if they added another suffix to the word suspect. So it's closest to if they called you suspectable in extremism and suspectable in terrorism.
对吧？所以它就像，如果他们在“嫌疑”这个词上加了另一个后缀。所以它最接近于如果他们称你为“在极端主义方面有嫌疑可能性”和“在恐怖主义方面有嫌疑可能性”。
Yes.
是的。
It's like this internal list is the draft of a list. Eventually, Zoya will probably be brought up on charges. She'll be the suspect in a made-up crime. But for now, in draft form, she is merely suspectable.
就像这个内部名单是名单的草稿。最终，卓雅可能会被起诉。她将成为捏造罪行的嫌疑人。但目前，在草稿形式中，她仅仅是“有嫌疑可能性”。
Can you tell me why you were trying to buy this information?
你能告诉我你为什么要买这些信息吗？
I think it's for me to understand the reality around me. Because when you are inside country, you very often don't feel that it's risky to stay there. And when you get this information, you understand it now. You cannot be safe. You have to be prepared every day that you could be arrested.
我想是为了让我了解周围的现实。因为当你身处国家内部时，你经常感觉不到待在那里有风险。当你得到这个信息时，你现在明白了。你不能是安全的。你必须每天做好准备，你可能会被逮捕。
They could come to your flat. And it's not a question will they come or not. They will. Just the question is, when? And will you have time to leave the country? Will you have time to say goodbye for your parents or not?
他们可能会来到你的公寓。这不是他们会来还是不会来的问题。他们会的。只是问题是，什么时候？你是否有时间离开这个国家？你是否有时间向你的父母说再见？
And what did Zoya do after finding out she was on this list of people who would eventually, probably be placed on the list of extremists and terrorists? She cried. She started making some plans for leaving the country someday. And she made one very practical plan for staying.
卓雅在发现自己在那些最终、可能会被列入极端分子和恐怖分子名单的人名单上后做了什么？她哭了。她开始计划有一天离开这个国家。她还制定了一个非常实用的留下的计划。
We bought a very good door. And when I came to the shop, I asked a guy to recommend me a door, the best, the best when police will come and they want to break this door. I need like 15 minutes, 20 minutes. And they choose this door for me. This was the main criteria.
我们买了一扇非常好的门。当我来到店里时，我让一个人给我推荐一扇门，最好的，最好的，当警察来想破门的时候。我需要大概15分钟，20分钟。他们为我选择了这扇门。这是主要的标准。
When you were buying the door, what did they think you needed it for?
当你买门的时候，他们认为你为什么需要它？
They thought that I'm a drug dealer. And the guy told me that, OK, you will have time to throw away to the toilet everything what you have. I didn't explain them why I need this door. I think that probably it's a more understandable reason for them.
他们认为我是毒贩。那个人告诉我，好吧，你有时间把所有你拥有的东西扔进马桶。我没有向他们解释我为什么需要这扇门。我想可能对他们来说这是一个更容易理解的原因。
Police usually come in the morning. Every evening before I'm going to sleep, I check the door, everything, all this, everything should be closed. Because if not, then I will not have this 20 minutes.
警察通常在早上来。我每天晚上睡觉前，检查门，所有这些，所有东西都应该锁上。因为如果不是，那我就没有那20分钟了。
How many locks does the door have?
门有几道锁？
Three.
三道。
And why do you need 20 minutes?
为什么你需要20分钟？
I need to clean my computer and contacts. Because if I will not do this, then all my friends will be in the risk. And also I have to fix my dog. My dog will protect me. And they could shoot dog.
我需要清理我的电脑和联系人。因为如果我不这样做，那么我所有的朋友都会陷入危险。而且我必须处理好我的狗。我的狗会保护我。他们可能会射杀狗。
So you have to put your dog in the other room?
所以你必须把你的狗放在另一个房间？
Yeah, in the bathroom. And ask them-- and kindly ask them to not touch him.
是的，在浴室里。并请求他们——温和地请求他们不要碰它。
Zoya has many reasons to stay in Russia. Since her sister died of cancer several years ago, Zoya and Zoya's mother have together been raising Zoya's niece. Zoya's parents don't want to leave. Zoya's partner doesn't want to leave. Most important, Zoya doesn't want to leave.
卓雅有许多留下来的理由。自从她姐姐几年前死于癌症后，卓雅和卓雅的母亲一直在抚养卓雅的侄女。卓雅的父母不想离开。卓雅的伴侣不想离开。最重要的是，卓雅不想离开。
So she has decided that she will stay as long as she possibly can. She believes the authorities will give her one final warning, something like leave the country now or go to jail, and then she'll leave. I'm not sure why she thinks there will be a warning. When it comes to her niece, though, Zoya is sure that the girl should leave the country as soon as she is old enough.
所以她决定只要可能，她就会待下去。她认为当局会给她最后一次警告，比如现在离开国家或者去坐牢，然后她就会离开。我不确定为什么她认为会有警告。不过当谈到她侄女时，卓雅确信那个女孩应该在年龄足够大时尽快离开国家。
I don't believe that she will have a future. I don't believe that life will be better in Russia. I see now how many people support Putin in these elections and how people celebrate it. And I wish all the best for my niece. I want her to live in a free country with the possibility to choose partners, work, opinion, everything.
我不相信她会有未来。我不相信俄罗斯的生活会变得更好。我现在看到有多少人在这次选举中支持普京，人们如何庆祝它。我为我侄女祝愿一切顺利。我希望她生活在一个自由的国家，有选择伴侣、工作、观点、一切的可能。
What if I said all the same things to you?
如果我也对你说同样的话呢？
It's good for someone that wish me all the best. But my niece, this is what I wish for her. But of course, she will decide.
有人祝愿我一切顺利是好事。但我的侄女，这是我为她祝愿的。但当然，她会自己决定。
Just before we sat down for our interview, Zoya told me something that was still pretty new to her too. She was pregnant.
就在我们坐下来采访之前，卓雅告诉了我一些对她来说也很新的事情。她怀孕了。
I am in a huge crisis now. Because today, all morning, I just cried. And I feel it how I start to care not about myself, but about the child.
我现在正处于巨大的危机中。因为今天，整个上午，我只是哭。我感觉到我开始关心的不是自己，而是孩子。
It's like this child, when they're born, will already be in one of those lists. Hannah Arendt called bureaucracy the rule by nobody. Maybe that's why it feels so hopeless. They label you an extremist or a foreign agent, and next thing you know, you're using those terms yourself to describe your life.
就像这个孩子，当他们出生时，已经会在那些列表之一上了。汉娜·阿伦特称官僚政治为“无人统治”。也许这就是为什么它感觉如此绝望。他们给你贴上极端分子或外国代理人的标签，接下来你知道的就是你自己也在用这些术语来描述你的生活。
Because it is your life-- thinking about where you can go, what you can say in public, how you're being singled out by the Russian state can affect people you love, and how it can always, always get worse. And you're never not going to think about it.
因为那是你的生活——思考你可以去哪里，你在公共场合可以说什么，你如何被俄罗斯国家单独列出可能影响你所爱的人，以及它如何总是、总是变得更糟。你永远不会不去想它。
M. Gessen is a staff writer at The New Yorker and the author of several books, most recently The Future is History.
M·格森是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，也是几本书的作者，最近的一本是《未来是历史》。
This program was produced and edited by Nancy Updike and me. Nancy also produced M. Gessen's story. People who put together today's show today include Michael Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, and Matt Tierney.
这个节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我制作和编辑。南希也制作了M·格森的故事。今天整理节目的人包括迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、安德里亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多（Andrea López Cruzado）、艾薇娃·德科恩菲尔德、贝瑟尔·哈布特（Bethel Habte）、卡西·豪利（Cassie Howley）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、萨菲亚·里德尔（Safiyah Riddle）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、阿里莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特（Marisa Robertson-Textor）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。
Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. And our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Elijah Wallechinsky, Lika Kremer, Jinae West, Isaac Arnsdorf, and Martine Powers. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。今天特别感谢以利亚·瓦莱钦斯基、丽卡·克雷默（Lika Kremer）、吉奈·韦斯特（Jinae West）、艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫（Isaac Arnsdorf）和马丁·鲍尔斯（Martine Powers）。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
If you need something to listen to, you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
如果你需要听点什么，你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. How does he describe his own management style? In a list with three main points.
一如既往地感谢我们的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他如何描述他自己的管理风格？在一个有三个要点的列表中。
Strong, hostile, and small-minded.
强大、敌对和心胸狭窄。
Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。